Our interval would be from negative 4 to positive 2. x could actually equal
negative 4 and positive 2 in this case, and any value in between them. Great
solving if you found this interval. To begin solving this inequality, we
want to subtract 8 from both sides. This allows us to set this quadratic
expression less than or equal to 0. Now, we can rewrite this as an equation and
find the 0s or the x values that make this equal to 0. We factor the quadratic
expression, and then we set each factor equal to 0 to get x could equal
negative 4 or x could equal positive 2. We use these to create the three
separate intervals on our number line. Next, we want to test a value in each of
the intervals. For the first interval, we'll test the value x equals negative
5. So plugging in the value of negative 5 in for x, we'll get the statement 7
is less than or equal to 0. Now, this of course, isn't true, so this interval
is false. It's not part of our solution. For the second interval, we can test x
equal 0. If x equals 0, we lose these two terms and we're left with negative 8
is less than or equal to 0. This, we know is true, so this part is included in
our answer. And finally, for the third interval, if we test x is equal to 3,
we'll get the statement 7 is less than or equal to 0. Again, we know this isn't
true, so this region is out. So the values of x that satisfy our inequality are
between negative 4 and 2. We include negative 4 and 2, since we have the or
equal to symbol here. Since we know both of these values are 0s to the
quadratic equation. I hope you're starting to see all sorts of patterns when
you solve these types of problems.